Four three,
two,
one.
All right,
we'll live.
What's up man?
What's up dude?
What's hilarious folks?
I have to tell you this.
I did a podcast earlier today and he said,
wow,
is your second for the day?
He goes,
impressive endurance.
Do you know how fucking ridiculous that is for you to say,
this is a guy who walked across Antarctica.
How many days did it take you?
54 days by yourself.
By myself checking the fucking frozen Tundra it,
that was an endurance feat of its own.
Yeah.
Just Bell.
That's a real endurance feed.
I'm just sitting down talking to people.
Oh my God.
You talked already for two hours.
How do you do it?
Two more hours.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Yup.
To what the fuck were you doing?
Just just getting back.
Actually.
Still,
uh,
still practically have the snow on my shoes.
Yeah.
I got back about a month ago.
54 day journey.
First person in history to cross the entire continent.
Solo unsupported.
So no resupplies throughout the thing.
No,
no aid,
no wind kites,
nothing.
Just me dragging a 375 pound sled across Antarctica.
I can't believe it only took you 54 days.
Yeah,
it's so big.
We can look at an article on a map,
like how long do you think it would take you to walk across America?
Well,
you got it.
So we usually look at Antarctica map.
This is hilarious.
I have show people a picture of Antarctica.
You're a smart guy.
You probably noticed,
but usually people see it on a map projection because then it gets flat.
Right?
It's actually circular.
Um,
so I went from the edge of the Ron I shelf to the,
uh,
via the south pole to the Ross ice shelf.
So basically kind of a diagonal across,
through the center and then back to the other ice shelf.
What do the flat earthers think about?
You're traversing this,
this area.
This is what you did.
This is how you,
there it is.
Exactly.
Yes.
We went to the center of the fucking earth basically.
There it is the top of the pole,
yet bottom of the earth,
you know,
standing down there holding everyone up on my shoulders.
Wow.
So you were at the South Pole and then you trucked over to the,
to the ice shelf on the other side.
It's funny you say about the flat earthers though because all jokes aside,
I been getting a lot of trolling on my Instagram page from the flat earthers.
I've got guys go,
I'm like,
oh,
I was doing this speech the other day.
People are Super Nice.
Come up in the Q and a afterwards,
want to shake my head and take a picture,
whatever.
And this guy walks up and this real earnest look on his face and he's like,
so I really wanted to ask you how was the whole?
And I was like,
excuse me.
He was like,
he know the hole at the center and I was like,
give me a little more.
He was like,
you know like when you got to the edge
and I was like,
Oh man,
like you're really asking this question right now like we are talking about,
because I didn't quite know where to go with it.
I was like,
yeah,
there was actually,
I at least I didn't see the edge and the curvature kept going in a minute is
such a strange thing to believe,
but people do that.
People think people are trolling about that and you know what,
it actually started out,
it's another four Chan thing,
you know?
Did you know that it's,
well I'm sure there was probably somebody believed it before that,
but it started off people trolling on four and then eventually people just
started actually going,
hey,
it is flat.
And then they started believing it and videos,
youtube videos.
There's another youtube video of someone linked to me the other day and I
thought it had like,
I thought it had like a few hundred views.
We had 28,000 views.
There was always guys debating like Colin proof that there's not a wall.
The wall,
like there would be like game of Thrones at the edge of the world.
There's this whole conversation.
I bet there's another 28,000 people.
It's proved the call and never actually weren't,
oh he's a new world order shill.
We'll,
the other,
the other buddy wide was that we got up budge on the Instagram page.
I'm out there alone completely by myself,
but I wanted to share the whole story through my
Graham to like share that journey with people,
inspire others to do whatever they want to do.
And it kept being like,
well,
I mean he's not out there alone.
He's taking pictures.
It was like the film crew as like guys,
have you never heard of a tripod?
And if in a timer watch survivor man.
Exactly.
So it's so,
it's so funny.
Comments along those lines.
So your,
your sled was 300 and how many pounds?
375 pounds to start.
Basically food and fuel was the main,
the main way.
So people,
I called my project the impossible first.
That's sort of what I named the project because several
people would try it right there.
So not only walking,
you're dragging this big ass heavy sled.
Yeah,
yeah.
And look dude,
people,
so people have tried this,
uh,
you know,
going back a hundred years to sh Ernest Shackleton saying if it was possible.
And then the last few years,
some really experienced polar explorers have given it a shot.
And one guy actually died less than a hundred miles from the finish line because
of lack of nutrition and some challenges with the weather and things like that.
Um,
but people called it,
you know,
people after that,
we're like,
it's impossible.
And the reason people thought it was impossible because you can't get
resupplies.
Meaning if you feel your sled with food and a certain amount,
you actually can't drag this led anymore.
So the whole math equation really was figuring out just how much food and fuel I
could put in the sled.
The fuel melts the water,
so melts the ice into water essentially.
And that equaled the 375 pounds.
And to be truth,
I could barely pull it on the first day.
Like I a one hour into getting dropped off.
I'm dropped off completely alone out there in Antarctica.
I planned this project for a year,
you know,
uh,
and uh,
I get dropped off and after about one hour pulling 375 pounds sled through the
snow,
it's minus 25 degrees out.
I'm crying,
I'm literally crying and the tears in my goggles are starting to freeze.
And I'm like,
oh my God.
So I pick up my satellite phone,
I call home to my wife Jenna,
who also creates and plans all these projects with me.
And I'm like,
Babe,
uh,
I think we named the project the right thing.
The impossible first.
Yep.
It looks like it might be impossible to keep going.
So I'm one hour into a thousand mile journey.
Poetess led told everyone I'm going to do this and I'm already having those
doubts pull up.
Uh,
you know,
fortunately I was able to get a little bit further that day and 54 days later
and made it to the end.
How far did you get in the first day?
Well,
it's funny cause we show,
just show the map.
I actually,
you know,
it starts on the ice shelf,
which is basically the frozen sea ice and there's an edge of that where the
continent starts.
And so I have a way point on my gps that marks that.
So the plane that drops me off actually dropped me off on the ice shelf before
the continent starts.
And my first waypoint was kind of like the actual start.
And so one hour in,
I haven't even hit the real start.
So when she,
when I call her on the phone,
she's like,
because she knows the route and she's like,
well how far are you from the first way point,
which is where the actual start isn't.
And I'm like,
it's 0.63 more miles.
She's like,
it's half a mile.
You have a thousand more to go.
Like get to the first way point,
you know?
And I was like,
okay,
okay.
So I,
you know,
rallied myself,
got to the first way point and then finally got in my tent that night and just
kind of took a deep breath.
I think I was just overwhelmed by the magnitude of it.
I mean,
imagine being a speck in the middle of Antarctica alone,
these crazy temperatures,
you know,
all the excitement but fears of the journey ahead.
Um,
and 375 pounds on my back when the sleds,
when the snow's deep too loose snow makes 375 pounds,
even even heavier than if it's like light,
you know,
icier consolidated.
So yeah,
it was a,
it was a rough start to say the least.
Did you do any sort of test run pulling the sled anywhere else?
Yeah,
so the training element of it was pretty cool.
So,
um,
I actually said a few other world records previous to this in the mountains and
things we could talk about if you want.
But the,
uh,
the last year is I really committed to this project I decided is to obviously
start training specifically for this.
Um,
I needed to put on about 20 pounds of muscle.
I'm usually six foot one 65.
Pretty Lean.
I'd race triathlon professionally for a number of years and realized I needed to
be a bit bigger because I was going to lose so much weight.
Um,
and I found an amazing coach and Portland,
Oregon where I live.
This guy named Mike McCastle.
I don't know if you've ever heard of him,
but I know you've had,
you've had David Goggins on your show.
I take it.
So,
um,
Mike actually surpassed David's pullup record.
Mike did 5,804 pull ups in 20 hours.
Um,
I think Goggins at about 4,000,
which are both insane to me
cause I can do like another thousand.
And he was where Mike was wearing a 30 pound weight vest.
Yes.
Just to add insult to injury,
uh,
Mike McCastle absolute absolute legend.
So anyways,
a minute,
wait a minute.
5,000 fucking Chin ups with a weight vest on to that.
Barely can do 10.
I'm right there with you at like at pull ups are not,
I've got some other physical strength but the pullup department is not,
not my strong suit is fucking get this too.
Just cause I got to,
I got a big up by bad for a second.
That's his fourth road right here.
Also pulled a f two 50 truck,
20 miles across death valley in a harness.
So I'm trying to look for the best guy to teach me how to pull heavy Shang.
My God,
you got the gun.
I found the guy was like,
fuck this is the guy that out.
Does it just make you feel like such a pussy.
And the greatest thing about Mike,
you know,
big,
strong Jack Dude,
but like super soft spoken.
She's like,
he's like,
yeah,
did this popes.
So it was cool.
Like,
so anyways,
I to fucked with that
record so hard,
he could die and like come back to life and live a whole nother life and no
one's ever going to do it.
Yeah.
So anyways,
my training,
he would,
he was the guy went to him train out of this gym in Portland,
uh,
where,
where he trains out of and he just,
he got me bigger,
he got me stronger.
But he also did all sorts of bad ass crazy stuff.
I mean,
this is a physical challenge,
but it's more of a mental challenge in anything.
So he had me,
you know,
my hands in ice buckets,
doing planks to get my heart rate jacked up and then he'd be like,
get out of the water.
Then I pulled my hands out of the ice buckets.
Do you know I'd be a seated squat against the wall,
but then he would hand me Legos and so my hands are frozen,
my feet or an ice buckets now in a plank.
My heart rates,
you know,
one 90 and he's like,
put this Lego set together.
So the deck dexterity in my fingers,
the mental acuity to pull this all together,
there is this guy,
what a fucking savage discarded is.
He and he did that for veteran suicides.
Yeah,
exactly.
So he did,
he's got really,
really important missions behind all of his projects.
He calls them 12 labors in over his life.
He's trying to set 12 route world records and various things.
People that are just,
they're just designed different.
Yeah.
So he's the man.
But like this crazy training he came up with,
for me that was like the ice,
the water,
the mental acuity.
All of this was like,
he was like,
Yo,
you're going to be in Antarctica if your tent blows away,
when you're pulling it up,
you're dead.
Like the stakes are that high,
50 60 mile per hour winds.
Absolutely crazy.
Um,
so do you ever have an issue like that where you thought the tent could blow
away?
Um,
I think,
I don't know if you have it.
There's a clip on my Instagram.
I posted a few days ago of me of me setting up the tent and the minus 80 degrees
out,
60 mile per hour winds.
It's pretty gnarly.
But yeah,
I mean there was one time when the 10 almost did blow away from me yet.
There's this one,
there's one other one.
This is me getting into 10 looking like an absolute disaster when I get help
with audio.
But that's me.
That's me.
Whoa.
You're pulling ice.
I got caught on a massive storm.
I was just
so hard to get the tent up.
I didn't know if I was gonna be able to get it up or I was going to have to just
keep walking that.
Now,
hopefully these tent poles hold
man,
that was really intense.
How do you stay warm in that?
Uh,
so it's average temperature is about minus 25 minus 30,
uh,
in Antarctica.
But like I said,
when the wind jacks up,
uh,
I don't know if there's the other cup of me setting up the tip,
but if you get a chance to see that it's,
you know,
it's about Kimmy about minus 80 outside,
which it's hard to wrap your mind around that.
But I've tried to put it in perspective by saying I could take a cup of boiling
water and throw it in an air and immediately turns to ice.
Like that's,
that's,
that's the temperature would dealing with,
yeah.
This is me trying to,
uh,
keep the tent poles together.
Usually you have someone else to hold on to it,
but I'm alone.
I'm completely alone out there.
So this is me struggling with my tent,
just trying to keep it up.
I've got it tied down to my sled.
They're just battling battling the winds and the state.
Like I said,
the stakes are high.
If that blows away.
I don't have a spare tank.
I've got no extra weight in my sled to hold spare stuff.
So it's,
it's,
it's do or die quite literally in a moment like that have a patch kit.
I had a couple of things repaired,
a sewing kit,
a patch kit,
stuff like that.
But if the tent itself or the temples,
you know,
ripped apart
pretty much done.
And also you have to set up your tripod and film and then press stop and go back
and send it.
How are you keeping these batteries juiced up?
No,
this is,
this are the film crew man that was following me around that right of the
plateau film group there near the Ice Wall.
The uh,
no,
uh,
it was basically I had to keep the batteries warm by keeping them right against
my skin.
So I'd keep the batteries right against my skin and my body weight would keep it
warm.
And the second I wanted to take it out,
I pulled out real quick hit play and then it would usually last a minute or
third enough to get a little clip or something like that.
You couldn't just let it run,
but then it would completely freeze.
Even a full battery would be,
you know,
on zero battery by pretty quickly using solar panels to charge it.
Yeah.
So one crazy cool thing about Antarctica,
that time of year,
years,
it's 24 hours a day light.
And so the sun never sets.
So even when I'm on my tent in the middle of the night,
I'm ask earplugs to kind of pretend like it's nighttime,
but 24 hours a day light.
So solar panels,
I'm keeping everything charged.
Camera's phone,
batteries,
all that.
And Are you traveling with or are you using gps?
Yeah,
so I have some way points,
the gps way points that kind of led my path to the South Pole,
et cetera.
But most actually using a compass.
So I'd look at my gps maybe once every week or something like that.
Just cause the bearing,
the juice factor is actually just easier because,
so I basically had like a harness on front of me that would have my gps or my,
my compass kind of off my chest more or less because some of the clips we saw
the sun's out.
But actually more than half of the time the clouds would come in.
So it'd be just complete and utter whiteout.
I couldn't even see one step in front of me.
And so I'd actually have to just stare down at my compass,
keep it on this bearing.
And so imagine you can't see anything,
can't see one step in front of you.
I'm pulling a 300 pound sled,
1213 hours per day,
not listening to anything really complete dead silence and just staring at this
compass bearing all day long.
So
going crazy at all.
I mean,
the mental side of it was by far the most interesting side of it for me.
Um,
you know,
have a lifelong insurance athlete,
but really kind of an exploration into the mind.
It was what it was for me and why I was curious about it.
So spending all this time in silence.
I've done,
are you familiar with,
uh,
a vipassana meditation,
these tips?
So I've done a couple of these 10 days silent meditation retreats before this,
which is 10 days,
no reading,
no writing,
no eye contact.
Um,
kind of dove in to that piece of it.
But 54 days,
a load in Antarctica and complete silence was,
was next level of that.
For sure.